thanks for coming super excited to be
here at data Council
so before we begin just like a really
quick show of hands how many of you have
you have heard of hanging face
okay a lot of people that's good and how
many of you have heard of Ray
it's perfect okay
so unfortunately it's gonna be just me
Jose couldn't make it in the end but I
am a software engineer at any scale and
I'm on the libraries team so we deal
with the machine learning library is
built on top of rail and all of my work
is fully open source which I love and I
also contribute to other open source
projects such as pie carrot
a little bit about any scale so we are
the original creators of Rey which is a
unified framework for scalable computing
and our mission is to make scalable
compute for AI and ml in Python really
easy and super straightforward to use
and we do it because scaling is a
necessity and scaling is hard but we
want to make it as easy and simple as
possible for everyone
so yeah just a quick overview of the
agenda so we are going to go over the
state of ML and AI as it is today I will
quickly recap what hacking phase is for
those who may not know it but guessing
by the show of hands it's not going to
be necessary and then I'm going to go
over why distributed training is simply
unnecessity today and how you can
combine hugging phase Transformers and
Ray AI runtime or Ray air to make that
super easy and we'll conclude with a
quick demo
so the state of the ML and AI today I
mean it's been all over the news lately
right generative AI is all the rage we
started out with image generating models
such as stable diffusion Dali now open
AI is has released charge GPT is going
through sgpt4 we are seeing more and
more companies getting into the
generative AI business
such as anthropical here databricks even
so basically for natural language
processing tasks and for text
Generations the Transformer architecture
is the state of the art it's the most
widely used it has given the best
results so far and we have seen some
very impressive models come from that
but of course there are other uses for
generative AI than just generating text
so we can have more specialized models
for text specification for sentiment
analysis detecting toxicity content
moderation entity recognition and so on
and so on and of course you may say like
why do we need all those different
models when we have chat GPT there are
many different use cases for that so for
example you may want to have a model
that you have full control over or you
may want to have a small model that you
can run cheaply cheaper than it takes to
make API calls to open AI or you want a
model that is completely fine-tuned to
your data set
so I'm just gonna briefly skip over this
so Transformers is an architecture uh
for deep learning and I guess like the
basically all you need is the attention
is all you need paper but the key thing
for here from the Practical perspective
is that Transformers tend to be very
large models and they need quite a bit
of data to give good results and if a
model is large then that's gonna mean
it's not gonna only require a lot of
memory to fit the model in the first
place but it's also going to require a
lot of compute to train the model in a
or train or serve the model in a
reasonable time frame
uh
uh so briefly the the hanging phase
Transformers Library uh is a library for
python developers that provides an
opinionated high level API for mainly
natural language tasks but also
branching into computer vision and audio
processing
and what it provides is multiple
different model architectures as well as
integration with the hacking face Hub
which is a community where you can share
the models you can share the data sets
you can easily obtain pre-trained models
and you can very quickly start running
your own model you can very quickly
start fine-tuning it or do whatever you
want with it
so hiking face Transformers makes
applying machine learning and AI Easy by
very much simplifying the flow of the of
putting an ml model into production so
basically you can obtain a pre-trained
model from hanging face Hub it's like
one line of code to get it then you can
use the trainer abstraction in hacking
phase Transformers to fine tune it on
your data set and then you can use the
pipeline subtraction for inference so
basically three steps and you are done
so we have abstracted the complexities
of deep learning we have increased our
velocity it's very easy to experiment
with the high level API and we have a
plethora of pre-trained models and data
sets weights we can choose from and we
can all obtain all of those with just
one line of code so here's like an
example of a typical hacking phase
Transformers workflow we get the data
set we get the model from the Hub we
said the training arguments and with the
trainer abstraction and all we have to
do is call trainer.train right so that's
great
and of course if you want then we can
also like use hanging face accelerate if
you want a lower level API but we are
going to mainly focus on this
so the problem is that like even though
we have the API pretty much nailed down
uh the problem is that the
state-of-the-art models large
Transformers they need a lot of compute
to actually train
so if we look at like the increases in
model sizes and computing power that
have been happening well they are
growing exponentially
and the problem is that compute is just
not being able to keep up so more law
was stipulating the the computing power
of CPUs is going to double every 18
months but we can see that with deep
learning models the number of petaflops
required is 35x every 18 months and of
course we have Hardware accelerators
such as gpus or even more specialized
accelerators such as tpus and even
though Nvidia is doing some crazy stuff
on the hardware level like there is
always going to be this problem where
the models are always going to grow
larger than what the hardware can
provide so in other War it's uh the
problem is that we have a supply demand
problem and the only way to to quench
that demand for compute is to move
Beyond a single machine
and start using multiple machines so we
have to go distributed
there's no way out
but if we go distributed that introduces
multiple new problems so if we have one
machine developing is very easy
but if we go to multiple machines we
start running into new problems so first
of all our development velocity slows
down because we Now operate on multiple
machines we have to make changes on
multiple machines we have to set them up
we have to start to manage complex
infrastructure so now we suddenly have
to become experts in how to use AWS or
gcp and this is not something that we
want to do as machine learning Engineers
or data scientists what we want to do is
we want to focus on the model itself we
want to focus on the results we're
getting and not necessarily like how to
set up the infrastructure for it to run
in the first place and finally even
though we can get the training of the
model to scale if we cannot get other
parts of the machine learning pipeline
to scale as well so data ingest hyper
parameter optimization and then in
France the then we are just going to
keep running into bottlenecks and the
increases in speed we have gotten from
scaling out our training are just going
to basically get canceled out
so the solution that we have come up
with in Array is the ray AI runtime
which is Excalibur unified toolkit for
both data scientists and software
engineers
and it allows us to provide a flexible
pythonic framework for each step of the
ml workflow so for data ingest we have
Ray data sets for data processing we
also have very data sets rate train for
training gradient retune for tuning and
then for inference and serving we have
Ray serve
so just a little bit more about the ray
ion runtime so we can think of this
whole ecosystem of Ray AI runtime as
sort of a layered cake right so at the
very bottom we have the actual Cloud
providers that provide the hardware uh
for programs to to run uh up top at the
top of this we have Ray car which is
um our like the base low level library
that provides simple Primitives for
creating uh distributed applications on
top of that we as the library team at
any scale but also like multiple open
source contributors everything we do is
open source here we provide libraries
that serve as like a middle ground
between the low level uh Ray core and
higher level libraries so in Ray iron
runtime we have several libraries and
they in turn integrate with best of
breed tools that we are all familiar
with so for example pytorch scikit-learn
XG boost different hyper parameter
tuning libraries we have Integrations
with 1db ML flow
and so on and so on
so when do we want to use Ray air so
there are several situations we may want
to consider that so first of all we have
a single type of workload to scale so
let's say we are just doing hyper
parameter optimization we have a psychic
learn model we want to try out multiple
different hyper parameters and we want
to do it at scale we can use retune for
that and we do not have to change
anything else in our stack we can create
whole end-to-end machine learning
applications and platform with it
so we can combine the different
libraries we have in Ray air to create
an entire pipeline
we can run different ecosystem libraries
using unified apis so we provide
Integrations for hugging phase but also
XD boost circuit learn pytorch and so on
and finally this is something that we
are also seeing happen is that companies
and users start building their own
custom ml platforms using gray Air as
the way to basically as the execution
layer so Spotify Shopify instacart they
are all building
platforms on top of rare
and why would we want to use Ray air so
first of all it provides an efficient
data layer and distributed Object Store
so those are the advantages of Ray the
optimizations that we have in Ray allow
us to very efficiently share the data
between different nodes in a cluster
the API is completely python based so
you do not have to get out of your
python script to do anything basically
once you have a ray cluster you can stay
in the python script at all times
the ray core provides robust scheduling
and resource management
and if you build on top of raid then you
basically have the entire compute strata
abstracted away from you and the
challenges that we have outlined before
are addressed
so now when we come to combining hugging
phase and dry error
what we have done is we have provided an
integration for hacking face
Transformers which we call hagging Face
trainer
and if you want to use it it's very
simple so first of all we have
our existing hacking face code that we
want to scale up all we need to do is we
just need to put it in a function and
return the trainer object then we Define
a scaling config so this is array our
API we have for determining how you want
to assign resources to this job
and once you have array cluster already
set up and if you are even taking like
advantage of Ray autoscaler which can
automatically provision nodes from your
cloud provider then basically if you
want to increase the number of gpus you
are using all you have to do is just
change the number of workers
then we Define our hugging phase trainer
we use array data sets as a way to
ingest the data I will talk about that
later more and all we have to do is we
have to call trainer.fit so very
familiar API we have been inspired by
sakit learn and this result object that
we are getting is going to contain
different results such as metrics
checkpoints and so on so let me dive a
little bit deeper into the
implementation of the trainer itself
so under the hood
what we have is we are using the
Python's distributed backend which means
in practice that we can run distributed
data parallel or fsdp training honorary
cluster
and because we are not like because we
have taken a generic approach to it we
are only initializing the Python's
distributed backend that means you have
multiple ways of Distributing the model
available so you can do data parallel
training you can do model parallel
training uh and so on
we allowed to use the user defined
hugging face code without any changes
we automatically convert Ray data sets
to the format expected by hacking face
so you can use Ray data sets for
efficient data ingest and pre-processing
and Ray data sets allows you to also
parallelize the pre-processing and
handle data that is too big to fit into
memory of a single node we also provide
built-in logging and monitoring and this
is not yet available but it will be in
the next Ray release we'll have a
separate accelerate trainer if you
prefer the accelerate API to the
Transformers API
so what we basically do is we create
several reactors and you can think of an
actor as a stateful process
and those actors all talk to each other
using the python distributed backend so
that means for example you can also use
deep speed which takes advantage of the
Fighter's distributed back end and that
allows us to basically abstract away the
infrastructure because creating the
processes orchestrating the processes
assigning resources this is all taken
care of by Ray
and we can use both CPU and the GPU
workers and we can even combine them so
for example you can have data
pre-processing happen on CPU and you can
have training happen on GPU
so for data ingestion as I mentioned
before we use Ray data sets as a common
format and that allows us to easily read
from both disk and cloud or other
formats and this is fully distributed
which means that it integrates
seamlessly with the rest of our Pipeline
and it can handle data that is too big
to fit on one node or even the entire
cluster by using smart offloading to
disk
uh and we also provide several out of
the box spring processors for common ml
tasks such as data imputation
um or and so on and you can also write
your own user defined functions or udfs
uh to do map apply with
and if you define them that way so here
in the example we create a tokenized
function which uses a hugging phase
tokenizer and then we use array error
batch mapper if you pass that batch
mapper as a preprocessor into the
hugging phase trainer then that's going
to be associated with the checkpoint
obtained after the training so you're
going to have a guarantee that the same
pre-processing is going to be applied
during both training and later in France
so for logging and monitoring we are
reporting all of the metrics that we get
from hagging phase and we have a
callback API that you can use to
integrate with your favorite tools so we
provide out of the box callbacks for
tensorboard mlflow ways and biases Comet
Etc and we have open source contributors
contributing more Integrations and you
can of course use the API to to write
your own
uh and afterwards the results object
also contains some extra information
um
that you can later use for analysis of
the training
we provide automatic checkpointing so
just by setting
the thinking configuration you have
automatic checkpointing to Cloud you can
then resume the training from that
checkpoint so we have a checkpoint
obstruction
and because we have this automatic
checkpointing we also have automatic
resumption from checkpoint and that in
turn enables spot instance usage so if a
node goes down that we are that we are
using either due to some sort of an
issue or whether there because it was
preempted by the cloud provider then we
can automatically provision another node
and we can resume the training from
latest checkpoint and also that
checkpoint abstraction is used as a data
container for later inference and
serving
so here is the typical hacking phase
Transformers workload as I showed before
so now we are going to see how hard or
how easy it is to distribute it with Ray
train
so first of all all we have to do is put
the logic that was initializing the
model and the training arguments and the
trainer object from hacking face
Transformers into our function
then we instantiate the array our
hanging face strainer so we take in the
function that we've just created we take
in the scaling config and we take the
ray data set so we also have an API to
turn a hugging phase data set into array
data set but you can of course use
different data sets and different data
sources and Ray data sets can scale very
well so we have we have some users using
them on a petabyte scale
and we just call trainer.fit and we
obtain the results object and if we were
to specify any extra callbacks then we
would also get information back from
that
so just to summarize we use Ray data
sets for ingest we can use our existing
hacking face code and it integrates well
with the rest of the array r and one
other cool thing about Ray is that the
code you write on your laptop is also
going to run just as well on a cluster
compost of multiple nodes basically the
the fact that we are running something
on multiple machines is getting
abstracted
so the other Integrations we have with
the rest of Ray air so we can do hyper
parameter tuning with Ray air all we
have to do is basically just pass our
hanging face strainer into a tuner
object and that's going to run a
distributed hyper parameter tuning run
of our distributed training so it's
automatically going to take care of
nested parallelism and resource
allocation here
for inference and serving we have racer
for online inference
and we also have the predictor API for
offline inference and we can use that
checkpoint that you have obtained after
the training
to instantiate both race serve and the
batch predictor and because we are using
hanging face pipelines under the hood we
are going to get the same consistent
output as from non-distributed hugging
phase Transformers
yep so this is an example of how you
would do
batch predictions so we have a batch
predictor API we pass the checkpoint we
set the high invest predictor and then
we just need to pass array data set and
we can do prediction
so I have a quick demo I'm not sure if
I'll be able to show it in its entirety
uh
uh so let me just open it up
[Music]
so basically what we are going to do
here is we are going to take a gptj
model uh which by the way is also behind
the dolly model released by databricks
recently and the gptj was trained on Ray
and this is also another bit of trivia
Charter GPT was also trained on right
uh so what we have here is we have a
notebook
so all we have to do is we have to set
the number of workers we want we
instantiate the runtime environment
which ensures that we have the same
libraries on every node we get the tiny
Shakespeare data set so the tasks we
have I'm not sure if this is running
uh
now that I look at it well I think the
demo is going to have to stay in our
hearts then
but not not always lost the demo is
available so if you are interested you
can just quickly take a snapshot of that
and you can run it yourself
uh that being said this particular demo
because we're training a gptj model we
are doing that with deep speed because
it may not be able to fit on gpus with
16 gigabytes of GPU memory but it should
be able to fit on a GPU with 24
gigabytes so that would be A10 uh
so that's that's a bit of a bummer but I
mean we are almost a time anyway
uh so yeah that was a quick overview of
how you can easily scale up Transformers
fine tuning using gray Air and how you
can integrate it with the rest of the ml
pipeline
and a bit of a Shameless plug here we
are going to have a ray Summit where we
are going to talk more about the
different advances we have made in the
array air ecosystem
and thank you so much for attending
[Music]